what is going on YouTube ohhara here
today we will be talking about Luffy's
lifespan the proven reasons that it's
been shortened and what it means for the
future
as always guys if you haven't caught up
with the story yet be careful because
there will be spoilers ahead but now
without further ado let's get right into
it
so guys first of all before we start
looking at luffy's lifespan we should
talk a little bit about age in general
in the one-piece world now the first
thing that you should know is Luffy
himself is 17 when the story begins and
after the two years time skip
he's obviously 19 that's his current age
in the one-piece word itself age is a
little different from our real world so
people tend to get a little bit older
currently the oldest human known to us
in the story is dr. Cora ha
Chapas mentor she's a fresh 140 and 4
years old that doesn't mean though as
often is believed that people tend to
get that old in the one-piece world
actually she's considered very very old
unnaturally old for age so we can assume
that people tend to get older than
usually in our real world but it's
probably around a hundred years or a
little less so that's the first thing
that puts the lifespan discussion a
little bit into perspective the second
thing to consider when it comes to Luffy
is that Luffy himself has unnaturally
strong in a Jurek body not only is he
made from rubber but also has he trained
his body to a really really great extent
during his life starting from when he
was a child and is easy to forget that
Luffy himself is extraordinary in the
one-piece world since we get confronted
with stronger and stronger enemies on
the course of the journey it is easy to
neglect that Luffy himself is probably
one of the strongest characters in the
whole universe of one piece and we are
just dealing with the elite here so his
body and his physique in general can
injure things that a normal person or a
normal being and the one-piece world
couldn't withstand so now let's look at
the evidence and get a little bit more
into the reasons of why it's generally
believed that luffy's lifespan has been
significantly shortened so the first
real reason we know that luffy's
lifespan is a little bit in danger is of
course is high consume of meat so we
know that Luffy eats a lot of grilled
meat and fried meat and raw meat
basically only meat and of course the
fat from the meat is not really good for
the heart so that's the main reason
luffy's lifespan is in danger I'm of
course just kidding here no so
luffy of course takes a lot of his
powers and his energy from eating so
let's better not get into that let's
tell guys like have a salad hearing them
now the first real reason or at the
first instant that we confronted in the
story with something that's threatening
Luffy's life is the gear system that he
invents one of or basically the
foundation of all his most prominent
techniques and the first gear that is
introduced by luffy is gear ii where he
basically accelerates his blood speed or
his metabolism by pumping the blood in
his body faster through his body to
speed up and in his fight against Lucci
it's actually stated by Lucci that he
understands how Luffy's technique works
and at the same time he also understands
the pressure or the burden that it puts
on luffy's body so we basically learned
that the first really major development
in Luffy's technique like basically
putting him on another level is also the
reason that his life might be in danger
and is like one of the real big threats
to luffy self and this of course since
we know it's counting kind of for gear
to the question or discussion is is this
also true about gear 3 and especially
also for gear 4 now it is not officially
stated if gear 3 and 4 also reduce
luffy's lifespan or have an impact on it
but what we know is definitely that
really tells luffy after he developed
gear 4th that it definitely has an even
harder strain on him than gear 2 and
gear 3 and also we know that luffy if he
gets to a certain extent only a little
serious with someone he always uses one
of those gear techniques so we basically
have all of luffy's most prominent
fighting stances that pay a huge toll on
his body now some people have argued
that since luffy obviously mastered gear
2 and gear 3 to a whole nother level
after the time-skip
it might well be that the strain on his
body
is gone now now my opinion I don't think
that's the case I'm certainly sure that
he got better at it it's definitely more
efficient and I think it's very likely
that the strain on his body went down
but then again guys you have to consider
that the strain from the gears comes in
the first place from luffy altering his
physique and his biology so i'm not sure
if it's actually possible to get more
efficient at that in the sense that it's
less stressful on your body like
especially boosting your metabolism
sounds really really unhealthy to me and
especially doesn't sound like something
you can get better at so i would like to
know what you guys think about that too
and another reason that I think that
luffy hasn't got rid of those strains is
that it's never been stated that it's
kind of gone and i mean you can't say
well it might have happened
off screen it might just be straining
but then why would really talk about the
strain skia forehead on his body even
compared to gear 2 and gear 3 so in my
opinion that's a pretty clear sign that
it still pays a huge toll on luffy and
especially and now let's get a little
bit more into that gear fourth cause
your fourth as we know is the newest
addition into luffy stances and it is
the one that luffy obviously hasn't
mastered to that extent yet that it's
kind of effortless so we saw this
especially in the examples of the fights
against doflamingo and cut a curry while
against doflamingo luffy had to take a
10-minute break completely being unable
to do anything having to rely on others
to care for him against cutter curry he
was a lot quicker on his feet and was
running around and managing to flee now
I've altered the argument that he only
accepted he'll Bend dressrosa because he
kind of learned to trust his comrades
but I'm not so sure because it really
looked like he was completely exhausted
there so in my opinion he definitely
improved his gear fourth abilities
especially when in this fight with
category he also trained his observation
haki to another level so it was
definitely a training fight for luffy
but even if his gear fourth was on the
same level again
category and doflamingo which again I
doubt highly I think we still all agree
that Luffy definitely has room for
improvement when it comes to his
technique especially when he's gonna go
up against the young ko so I'm really
really sure that especially gear fourth
will have a huge impact on luffy's life
and health in the future of the story
especially in the upcoming fights now
for the next piece of evidence we move a
little bit forward in the story down to
imple down and here we actually get a
real hands-on experience on Luffy losing
some part of his life span so as you
guys might know Luffy went to him pull
down to three days before his execution
could take place and on his way to
rescue ace he met Miguel on and he was
completely obliterated by him and
drowned in his poison and Luffy was
pretty close to dying there but he was
actually brought to the base that even
Cove was operating her small country
inside the prison from and there she of
course started to treat Luffy and the
technique she used with her home on
hormone fruit was the so called Emporio
chill hormone which basically is a
special kind of healing hormone and how
it works is if you check those special
hormones into someone's body they
basically boost the immune system of a
person to its fullest extent so that is
basically the hidden secret to luffy's
miracle healing from a gallons poison
and since those hormones are only
unleashed on the immune system itself
the chances of someone really surviving
that wounds are there their pain is
basically based on that person's will to
live and since of course we know that
Luffy not only has a strong will of
himself but the will of Dee whatever
that means
he of course managed to pull through now
the downside of this technique is that a
certain amount of the targets lifespan
is actually needed to be able to apply
this technique and heal a person
so this lifespan has to be sacrificed to
kind of stand in for the energy that's
needed to to heal the damage that's been
done to
person and in Luffy's case since his
injuries and the poisoning was so severe
he won't Coast states that it will
probably take at least ten years of his
lifespan and this is like a very very
precise number here so we talked about
the age in one piece before people tend
to get old but still ten years or maybe
more that's definitely a huge blow and
at least one upside of this was that
Luffy has seemed to develop some kind of
immunity to most poisons they are now
during the war of the greatest
evanka again had to inject Luffy with
hormones this time it was his technique
of Emporio tension hormones which
basically have a different effect than
the healing hormones they don't affect
the immune system but rather pump
adrenaline into the body or make the
body generate more adrenaline and they
kind of have the effect of the person
being less tense and allowing him to
move more or move again in general be
more energetic basically for whole one
entire day the downside though again
being that after you've been injected
with this hormone the body will feel
completely exhausted and you will feel
really nauseous and again in luffy state
of being already completely weakened it
is not really clear if it might have
affected luffy's lifespan as well
now since those are basically the two
instances or three instances that we
really know of that luffy's lifespan has
been reduced of course there's still the
current storyline and as we know guys
one is gonna be crazy so we have Kaido
there we're gonna have big mom there the
Marines might come so it's definitely
gonna be all out there and Luffy will
definitely have to go all out himself
and that will mean that those really big
fights and battles with the yonkos and
the world government in the future they
might have a really big impact on his
health so Luffy's lifespan having been
shortened might actually play a role in
one or country already so I'm incredibly
curious if something will happen in that
regard and if you guys have any opinion
on this matter please share it with me
as well
senada we know that Luffy's lifespan has
probably been shortened significantly
and his life may even be in immediate
danger soon in the story the question is
of course what is the best solution to
counter this problem and as many of you
will probably already have heard here or
there a big theory that is thrown around
is that law will actually use the
ultimate technique of his devil fruit
the eternal youth surgery to save
luffy's life at one point and basically
give him eternal youth which of course
in my opinion wouldn't make him immortal
but make him immortal in the sense that
he wouldn't die of a natural age now
many people aren't that happy with that
theory because it would mean that law
would have to die for Luffy which I
wouldn't say is impossible I just think
that older might still have a curve ball
in there somewhere I am just not sure to
what that might be actually but I'm
really curious in regard to how this
issue will resolve in the future now the
last question that we want to look at is
well if nothing will save Luffy or
nothing will prevent his lifespan from
being that short will he actually die at
one point so it of course depends on oh
de whether he will have Luffy be healed
or not but if he tends to not healing
Luffy I think we all can agree on Luffy
not gonna not going to die before the
story is going to end so if anything it
will be close to the end of the manga
and I know a lot of people don't like
hearing this I personally don't know how
I would feel about that but at the same
time I'm sure Luffy dying the same way
that Roger or Whitebeard did with a
great smile on his face as he was
actually already prepared to do in loke
town when he was going to be executed by
buggy I think it wouldn't necessarily
make a bad finish for Luffy but I still
hope that he will pull through in the
end and anyway guys who can tell how the
story will go on it's just a thought of
mine now guys I hope I could clear up
and lay out the issue of luffy's
lifespan and his immediate threat to his
life a little bit and help you
understand better why it might be
important in the current storyline
I'm incredibly curious on what you guys
think about the topic so share it in the
comments below
otherwise guys if you liked the video
please leave me a thumbs up if you
didn't leave me a thumbs down don't
forget to subscribe if you want to be
notified for any future content of mine
and otherwise I wish you all the best
and I hear you next week
you
[Music]